do you believe Christianity is
inherently better than the other
abrahamic religions and if you do why
well I'm a Christian so of course I
believe in Christianity and in as much
as a religion contradicts Christianity I
don't believe in that religion so a
brief explanation for the hope that
lives within me I suppose is I believe
that uh Jesus Christ is who he says he
is I believe in God the Father Almighty
maker of heaven and Earth and in Jesus
Christ his only son our Lord I believe
that he was uh begotten of the of the
Holy Spirit born of the Virgin Mary he
became man the second person of the Holy
Trinity dwelt Among Us lived uh was
crucified died and was buried harrowed
hell and redeemed mankind I think he was
resurrected on the third day this would
be one sign of that I think there 500
eyewitnesses to the resurrection I think
the apostles all went off uh to the
various corners of the earth most of
them to be killed I don't think they
would have done that for a joke I don't
think they would have done that because
they were all just totally crazy I don't
think they were all mistaken I just
think the evidence is very strong